bonsoir à tous nous sommes le mercredi
18 mai merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
comme chaque jour nous revenons sur
votre actualité locale entouré de nous
inviter mais également des journalistes
de la rédaction tout de suite les titres
de cette édition la première auto école
sociale des yvelines a ouvert en
décembre dernier à versailles retour sur
les premiers résultats de ce dispositif
d'insertion sociale qui a été présenté
hier par le département et la semaine
derière aurore bergé et lui les
républicains de l'opposition de magny
les hameaux dénoncer le sexisme en
politique et notamment des faits dont
elle a été victime la semaine dernière
lors du conseil d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
elle est notre invité ce soir nous
reviendrons avec elle sur ce sujet et
enfin deuxième épisode de notre série
consacrée aux yvelinois présent sur la
croisette à l'occasion du festival de
cannes
aujourd'hui vous allez découvrir des
jeunes talents originaires de notre
département mais aussi des stars déjà
confirmés comme un certain omar sy et
nous commençons ce journal avec à la
mobilisation des syndicats de police qui
a eu lieu aujourd'hui à paris les forces
de police ont manifesté aujourd'hui
place de la république objectif dénoncer
la haine anti policiers en france depuis
l'ouverture du débat sur la loi travail
selon les syndicats de police 350 agents
ont été blessés en deux mois dans
l'hexagone
la mobilisation a réuni aujourd'hui près
de 2000 personnes dont une centaine
venus des yvelines on écoute où tu lire
le cam le secrétaire adjoint du syndicat
alliance 78 il était présent la
manifestation les collègues yvelinois
ont été invités dont 4 rassemblés place
de la république avec les parisiens
donc il y avait de nombreux collègues
les différents commissariat de trappes
elancourt versailles qui nous ont
rejoints place de la république
et cet après midi à elle encourt une
vingtaine de jeunes de saint quentin en
yvelines ont participé au sit in game
nous rencontre de street football au
city stade de la ville un projet mené
depuis un mois par l'ufolep de plaisir
fédération sportive multisports
il s'inscrit dans le cadre du label tous
prêts créé à l'occasion
l'euro 2016 par la fédération française
de football le ministère des sports de
la ville et de la jeunesse
l'objectif organiser des événements
sportifs à destination des jeunes de 10
à 17 ans issus des quartiers
prioritaires écoutez c'est faire un
événement autour du fair play qui
s'étalera donc leur apporter certaines
actions qu'est-ce que par leur apporter
le fair play qui sera donc le respect le
la maîtrise de soi la loyauté et c'est
qu'on peut avoir sur un terrain et c'est
aussi la ligne directive de l'euro 2016
le respecte de ses camarades de ses
collègues et tout ça donc c'est ce qu'on
a envie d'instaurer aujourd'hui en fait
on fait ça tous les mercredis après midi
et maintenant ça ça fait un mois qu'on
est dessus et donc on opère surtout
l'île de france est donc là on a déjà
fait trois événements dans les yvelines
et je vous le disais en titre la
première auto école sociale des yvelines
a ouvert en décembre dernier à
versailles
le département avait missionné
l'association sauvegarde de l'enfant de
l'adolescent et de l'adulte dans les
yvelines qui présentait hier les
premiers résultats de ces candidats un
dispositif d'insertion sociale qui
semble être une réussite puisque le
conseil départemental soutiendra
l'ouverture d'une nouvelle auto école
sociale au mois de septembre à mantes la
jolie
les précisions de william l c'est une
première dans les yvelines à versailles
une auto école sociale a vu le jour en
décembre dernier un dispositif
d'insertion partenariale porté par le
conseil départemental est soutenu par
une aide de 200 mille euros du fonds
social européen
cette auto école sociale comme son nom
l'indiqué tire son importance du fait
que l'accès à l'emploi est totalement
empêché par l'absence de permis
surtout quand on est en grande couronne
de la région parisienne parce que
l'offre de transports en commun étaient
insuffisantes
le permis souvent indispensable pour
accéder à l'emploi en zone rurale un
précieux sésame qui revient généralement
trop cher dans une auto école classique
ce qu'elle est différent par rapport à
une auto écoles classiques c'est déjà
les moyens d'intégrer cette auto école
puisque en fait personne ne vient
inscrire en direct ça passe toujours par
des référents sociaux actuellement nac
et surtout des bénéficiaires rsa des
personnes ayant la prime d'activité sous
réserve d'un certain financement mais
aussi des demandeurs d'emploi dans le
cadre de l'accompagnement global
ici les modalités d'enseignement sont
différentes
la formation est adaptée au profil de
chacun dans des classes de 10 à 15
personnes pour une moyenne de dix heures
de cours de code par semaine dans une
haute école classique on corrige pas à
quoi ils ne disent pas nos erreurs s'est
on voit là encore il nous en informons
sais pas pourquoi alors qu'ici nous
explique pour quelles raisons d'un faux
quoi j'ai eu beaucoup moins de mal à
pouvoir avoir le cot la première fois se
développer et après j'ai retravaillé
pendant trois semaines à fond avec le
moniteur et c'est vrai que gelée au
deuxième une participation de 250 euros
minimum est demandé à chaque participant
sur les 20 premiers adhérents quatre
personnes ont déjà obtenu leur permis
un résultat qui semble être une réussite
puisque en septembre une seconde auto
école sociale verra le jour à mantes la
jolie et nous recevons ce soir aurore
bergé élus républicains dans l'opposé
les républicains pardon dolan position
de magny les hameaux vont sort avant ça
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes exprimé la semaine la semaine
dernière via twitter mais c'est sur
différents médias nationaux pour parler
de ce qui s'est passé lundi dernier lors
du conseil d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
alors vous l'assuré vous avez été la
cible de remarques sexistes suite à la
sphère beaupain de la faim ou pas je le
rappelle le député écologiste est accusé
d'agression sexuelle et de harcèlement à
csu sexuelle est ce que c'est cette
affaire qui vous a poussé à témoigner
après ce qui s'est passé lors du conseil
d'agglomération
oui tout à fait c'est à dire que la
ferme aux pinsons une femme qui ensemble
ont eu le courage de parler sur des
faits soit de tentative d'agression
sexuelle soit de harcèlement sexuel ce
qui est assez nouveau en politique que
les femmes osent prendre la parole sur
le sujet parce que vous savez c'est
toujours un peu cette représentation
politique des femmes qui sera un peu des
petites choses fragiles seraient trop
émotive qui serait pas vraiment adapté
du coup à ce que l'on attend normalement
des politiques et c'est parfois avec lui
comme un aveu de faiblesse juste de dire
la manière avec laquelle les choses se
passent elles l ont fait et c'est vrai
que moi j'étais encore plus sidéré
qu'on puisse tenir à mon égard ce type
de propos le soir même des révélations
de la sphère beaupain avec des élus qui
en plus font référence directement à
cette affaire pour recommencer sur des
blagues machistes sexistes et graveleuse
donc la fin voilà a été entendue est
sorti vous êtes exprimés donc à
différentes reprises sur donc les deux
élus qui ont fait des remarques sexistes
à votre rencontre
vous allez récolter de nombreux soutiens
vous aurez suffisamment écoutés en tout
cas moi j'ai été à la fois très heureuse
de voir que les soutiens venait vraiment
de toutes parts et pas uniquement non
partis politiques y compris dans les
élus du département donc ça je pense que
c'est important parce que à la fois
malheureusement le machisme est quelque
chose de partager entre tous les partis
mais aussi la lutte pour les questions
d'égalité homme-femme et le droit des
femmes doit être partagée avec tous les
partis j'ai surtout été très frappé par
le nombre de témoignages que j'ai reçus
de la part de femmes vraiment des
dizaines et dizaines de témoignages
police et non politique vraiment de tout
milieu des gens qui vous grise sur
facebook qui se trouve un mail ou sur
twitter etc et qui me partage est à la
fois leur contentement du fait que
quelqu'un puisse prendre la parole sur
un sujet qui est très peu abordée en
général et en même temps leur grande
solitude la difficulté pour les femmes
c'est de trouver le bon interlocuteur
pour pouvoir s'exprimer quand elles sont
prêtes à le faire ce qui n'est pas
évident parce qu'il ya toujours cette
forme de culpabilisation que j'ai
ressentie aussi vous vous remettez en
question où vous dites que c'est vous
qui avait provoqué quelque chose si ce
comportement est arrivé est évidemment
c'est pas l'attitude à avoir ce n'est
pas nous qui sommes en cause c'est bien
ce qu'ils ont ce genre de propos ce
genre de geste mais encore faut-il quand
vous êtes prête à prendre la parole de
trouver le bon interlocuteur ou la bonne
interlocutrice parfois en face de vous
et c'est malheureusement assez rare et
encore plus en politique
en tout cas vous avez le courage de le
dénoncer vous avez récolté 2
mon soutien notamment celui de michel
logique s'est exprimé c'est à ceux là je
vous propose de l'écouter tout de suite
je condamne tout à fait les propos
machistes qui peuvent être tenues
surtout par des élus je crois qu'on doit
donner l'exemple et chacun doit rester à
sa place et on doit mesurer ses propos
surtout dans des conditions actuelles et
avec l'actualité que nous connaissons
chacun a le droit de s'exprimer
on re berger l'a fait je pense que elle
a peut-être pas non plus mesuré
l'ampleur que ça a pu prendre par la
suite mais en tout cas bien sûr je suis
solidaire et puis j'ai été le premier à
lui téléphonait immédiatement appelé
puisque moi treize années en effet je
m'attendais pas à l'ampleur que ça a
pris au départ j'ai publié ça en privé
sur facebook il était plus de minuit
lundi soir
hees et une journaliste qui est dans mes
relations et qu'il a publiées elles
mêmes sur twitter et là ça a pris
d'autres proportions michel m'a appelé
tout de suite et en quittant votre
plateau je vais aller le voir je sais
qu'il est très vigilants sur ces
questions là et si ça peut amener à un
nouveau mode de fonctionnement aussi au
sein de l'agglomération pour justement
avoir peut-être cette fameuse
interlocutrice qui existerait pas juste
pour les élus mais pour les agents de
l'agglomération parce que
malheureusement ça touche une femme sur
cinq dans notre pays donc ici aussi au
sein de votre rédaction comme un simple
d'agglomération alors sandrine album
qu'elle veut de l'opposition a donc à
saint quentin en yvelines a déclaré le
mal est fait le malaise est là la
suspicion aussi faux de savoir qui sont
les deux élus incriminés car vous n'avez
pas donné ces noms c'est le comportement
de chaque élu de la majorité de droite
qui est interrogé et l'image de
l'agglomération qui est détachée a
demandé à michel l'objet le gel a exigé
des auteurs de ces propos qu'il en tire
les conséquences en présentant des
excuses et en renonçant à leurs mandats
exécutifs exécutif éventuel êtes
d'accord avec ça alors déjà je n'ai pas
donné les noms parce qu'il ya eu un
emballement médiatique assez importants
comme vous avez pu le voir
et moi mon but c'est pas de clouer au
pilori en place publique et scénarii pas
de leur âge ni ces personnes michel
auger est au courant
c'est le seul avec son chef de cabinet
savent qu'ils sont les deux personnes
qui ont tenu ces propos
je sais qu'il va les voir et je sais
qu'il va leur en parler et ça lui
appartient à près de prendre les mesures
qui s'imposent mois ce qui m'importait
c'était d'avoir un témoignage personnel
et que ces deux personnes comprennent
pourquoi ces propos étaient blé sont
choquants anachronique et ne devaient
plus se tenir
la gauche enfin argument parce qu'on
savait que les choses sont un peu tendu
en ce moment l'agglomération entre la
majorité et l'opposition
et j'ai pas du tout envie que sous
couvert de solidarité avec moi ce soit
un nouveau prétexte pour créer de la
polémique sur l'agglomération ce
d'autant plus que la position de chaîne
logée sur le sujet elle est exemplaire
et ça ne valait pas plus de sanctions
c'est encore une fois moi je vois michel
laugier en sortant de votre plateau on
va en discuter ensemble
moi je veux surtout que ça permette de
mettre en place des solutions et les
solutions pour les femmes moi c'est pas
le sujet ma personne ce qui importe
c'est que ce genre de comportement ne se
reproduise plus que ces deux élus et
tous les autres comprennent que ces
propos ne pourront plus être tenu et que
quand bien même il continuerait les
femmes ne se ferait plus il est très
clair que si à l'avenir de nouveaux
propos étaient tenus là pour le coup
clairement je dirais qu'ils en sont les
auteurs lorsque christine boutin
ancienne ministre du logement et député
des yvelines conseillère régionale
également dit qu'elle a honte de ses
ancien ministre qui dénonce le sexisme
17 ministres dont qui se sont exprimés
dans une tribune suite à la sphère
beaupain elle dit que c'est la
discrédite les politiques c'est un coup
de grâce pour la politique selon elle
quand on sait vous ça vous fait réagir
ça je trouve ça à téhéran en fait je
vous ça à teyran ne pas soutenir les
femmes qui elles osent parler tant mieux
si christine boutin n'a jamais été
victime de harcèlement sexuel mais
encore une fois il ya une femme sur cinq
en france qui en souffrent ça n'est pas
un petit sujet la question des violences
faites aux femmes ce n'est pas un petit
sujet et j'ai du mal à comprendre cette
prise de position là je sais pas si
c'est le fait d'avoir intériorisé parce
qu'elle est là depuis tellement
longtemps qu'elle considère que c'est
normal et que ça fait partie des règles
du jeu moi je considère qu'il faut les
changer ses règles du jeu et que c'est
anormal que des élus et les hommes se
comporte comme ça aujourd'hui encore en
france donc c'est un sujet dont on parle
voilà de plus en plus mais certainement
pas assez encore c'est assez récent est
ce que vous allez vous à vous engager
davantage justement sur ce sujet du
sexisme par rapport aux femmes ce qu'on
subit justement dans le travail ou en
vie politique la question des droits des
femmes pour moi elle est essentielle
jamais
un niveau de 6 en 2012 donc c'est un
sujet qui est ancien est important pour
moi c'est pas un sujet de bruit
médiatique ou de notoriété contrairement
à ce que certains aimeraient croire ou
laissent à penser
donc oui je vais continuer à me investir
je m'investis sur ce sujet aussi auprès
d'alain juppé puisque je suis dans son
équipe de campagne
et de toute façon je vais y réfléchir
aussi avec d'autres femmes d'autres
partis politiques pour voir quelles sont
les propositions qu'on peut émettre sur
le sujet ensemble
merci au revoir et merci à vous de
répondre à nos questions
tout autre sujet à présent la semaine
dernière à versailles la créatrice de
mode agnès b s'est rendu au 7 rue de la
paroisse pour inaugurer une nouvelle
boutique c'est la première enseigne de
la créatrice qui voit le jour dans la
ville du roi soleil dont elle est native
et où elle a vécu jusqu'à l'âge de
dix-sept ont un retour aux sources qui
survient le lendemain de sa décoration
par le président de la république comme
commandeur de la légion d'honneur
william el est patrick jacques de
dixmude pour ce reportage
pour la créatrice c'est comme un retour
aux sources
originaire de versailles où elle a
grandi jusqu'à ses 17 ans agnès b a
ouvert le 10 mai dernier la première
enseigne de sa marque dans la ville du
roi soleil
quarante ans après l'ouverture de son
premier point de vente à paris j'ai
voulu rester un peu versaillaise
seulement alors on est resté dans des
tons
c'est gris clair que j'adore les volets
gris clair comme ça la maison et jaune
fans alors on est resté avec des stores
jaune pâle on a voulu coller au
contraire architecture au le plaquer un
truc qui aurait été différent c'est ça
que j'ai voulu faire une boutique qui
lui ressemble
avec 90 mètres carrés de surface qui
s'étale sur trois pièces et un espace
pour les hommes qui seront l'objet de sa
première collection la nouvelle
collection c'est l'homme que je présente
le 24 juin
voilà alors c'est l'homme était prochain
qui j'ai déjà fait divers j'ai présenté
mois de janvier après yahoo live sa
femme juin l'homme et octobre la femme
puisque d'emploi du temps surchargé pour
la créatrice qui enchaîne collections et
des filets dont le travail a été
récompensé la veille par le président de
la réponse était commandeur de la légion
d'honneur avec une cravate rouge avec la
légion d'honneur
c'était émouvant de émouvant pour moi de
remercier un faible enthousiasme et une
énergie que la créatrice a su mettre à
profit dans son travail
une nouvelle boutique dans une ville
qu'elle dit n'avoir jamais quitté qui
s'ajoutent 250 enseignes qui s'exporte
même à l'international est toujours
parlons un mode samedi dernier le centre
juan les chaînes paris aux
clayes-sous-bois proposé quatre défilés
d'articles de mode à prix réduit la
structure présenter des collections
homme femme et enfant printemps-été 2016
mettant en avant les commente qu'elle
accueille
elodie gossuin grandes stars mannequin
est né ce conduit l'un présentait les
défilés pour le plus grand bonheur des
plus jeunes et je ne peux pas le prendre
pour moi je pense je le prends plutôt
par rapport à l'événement dans sa
globalité voilà ça fait partie de tels
événements des défilés de la danse voilà
deux
c'est de créer quelque chose qui
transmettent une petite part de magie
effectivement je pense que ça ne peut
nous faire que du bien et à tout un
chacun
voilà c'est aussi de rêver de partager
et puis deux
de montrer aussi ce que l'on sait faire
à localement et de donner envie de le
partager avec les gens et nous passons
maintenant à notre chronique dès
aujourd'hui pendant cinq jours la france
fait la nature plus de mise animations
gratuites sont proposées au public en
ile-de-france des lieux habituellement
fermés ouvrent leurs portes pour
sensibiliser les curieux à la protection
et au respect de la nature pour en
parler et découvrir le programme de
cette édition ce soir en plateau avec
nom mélanie potet bonsoir mélanie ce nom
sans floral alors la fête de la nature
elle fête cette année ses 10 ans elle
est à l'initiative du comité français de
l'union internationale pour la
conservation de la nature et terre
sauvage un magazine spécialisé
elle est organisée par l'association
fête de la nature qui rassemble des
acteurs nationaux comme l'office
national des forêts ou le muséum
national d'histoire naturelle mais aussi
des acteurs régionaux comme natureparif
l'agencé régionale pour la nature et la
biodiversité en ile de france bruno myle
yens son président nous en explique les
buts les vecteurs qui opère auprès de la
batture que ce soit vigie nature que ce
soit nature pas ce soit mais des maires
qui sont qui sont qui sont sensibilisés
à cela que ce soit l'opinion sucre et
d'autres que ce soit la fève etc ont
participé à cette fête de la nature
les gens qui viendront découvrir des
choses dont on n'imaginait même pas
l'existence et de l'importance tous ces
petits trucs pour essayer de comprendre
que la nature ce qu'elles étaient avant
ce qu'elle est devenue pourquoi il faut
qu'on ment réintroduisent la fête de la
nature est importante pour soi ce sont
ces petits attendu par le public l'an
dernier 200 mille personnes avaient
participé à cette semaine sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines nature donne aussi rendez vous
au plumitif et les animations ont même
commencé déjà depuis ce matin avec
l'opie office pour les insectes et leur
environnement qui est basé à guyancourt
les plus jeunes ont été un des invités à
découvrir les petites bêtes dans leur
milieu de vie mais aussi ont été un
court instant de petits entomologiste
mais l'office propose d'autres
animations mathieu de flores chargé de
mission vous donne un rendez vous l'eau
qui s'occupent d'un
eux qui appartient à louer nef donc
l'office national des forêts on appelle
ce milieu on espaces l'espace nature du
val d'or qui est au niveau des étangs de
la minière c'est un espace qui a accès
exceptionnel parce qu'en fait il est
entièrement fermé au public qu'en temps
normal à part pour des animations mais
donc on a laissé on l'a clôturée et on a
laisser la nature reprendre un peu ses
droits
on va vous faire découvrir les petites
bêtes qui habite dans ce milieu là qui
est à deux pas de versailles et on a
vraiment eu l'impression d'être perdu
dans la nature alors qu'on est vraiment
on est vraiment ararat cinq minutes de
versailles en voiture et pour les plus
grands qui voudraient eux aussi
découvrir le métier d'entomologiste
l'oppidum rendez-vous à châteaufort le
samedi 21 mai de 15 heures à 17 heures
et si vous n'avez jamais eu l'occasion
d'entrer au sein de la réserve naturelle
de saint quentin en yvelines
cette dernière ouvre ses portes pour une
visite guidée c'est toujours le 21 mai
mais lassé de 14h à 16h30
attention la réservation est obligatoire
pour tous et rendez vous pour le 22 mai
le dernier jour de la fête de la nature
c'est aussi la journée internationale de
la biodiversité
alors pour découvrir ou redécouvrir les
lieux et viennois et s'informer sur la
biodiversité et ses acteurs le programme
est à retrouver sur le site internet de
la fête de la nature merci à mes l'année
parlons culture à présent jusqu'au 22
mai également le théâtre est à l'honneur
à voisins le bretonneux l'association
club jeune théâtre a lancé vendredi
dernier son festival pendant plus d'une
semaine d'une semaine par dont cinq
pièces seront représentés à la salle de
la tour des pièces jouées par des
enfants et des adolescents qui ont
parfois revisiter les grands classiques
comme ici le petit prince une pièce à
laquelle william el est patrick jacques
de dixmude ont assisté pour certains
c'est la première fois qu'ils vont
monter sur scène devant un public les
enfants ou un peu le trac alors
pascaline donne ses derniers conseils
avant la représentation
je pense que ça leur permet
d'extérioriser ce qu'ils peuvent pas et
faire à l'école par exemple pour vous
avec leurs parents il exprime pas les
choses de la même façon
il aime beaucoup être avec les autres
faire un book air une pièce comme ça
tous ensemble et tenait quelque chose de
bien à la fin de la vie
cette pièce c'est le petit prince dans
une nouvelle version revisitée où trois
comédiens différents vont interpréter le
garçon aux cheveux blonds en gros ça
raconte une histoire de trois petits
princes qui parle dans leur planète
ensuite ils vont visiter des autres
planètes
on a commencé depuis le début de l'année
on a fait une répétition de la première
partie en novembre ensuite bas on en
rêve isère à deuxième et la première
plus on est prêt c'est sympa on peut
exprimer
on peut s'exprimer comme on veut il m'a
fallu deux fois à prendre leurs peurs
coeur je connais bien maintenant encore
j'apprends les rôles sont les théâtres
et bunge des retient toujours après en
plus de cette pièce jouée exclusivement
par les enfants l'association club jeune
théâtre propose dans le cadre de son
festival
quatre autres pièces à découvrir
jusqu'au 22 mai et enfin c'est notre
rendez-vous à de la semaine deuxième
épisode de notre série consacrée au
festival de cannes mais surtout aux
yvelinois qui participent à l'événement
aujourd'hui nous allons vous faire
découvrir des jeunes talents de notre
département une comédienne armelle
habibou une réalisatrice et charlotte
marcos toutes les deux originaire de
sartrouville et puis un certain omar sy
talent ont déjà confirmés qui lui prête
sa voix au personnage raid dans angry
birds
alexis garneau gregory kane aller et
nicolas kirillovitch pour ce deuxième
reportage de notre série cannes à 78
du soleil la mer des palmiers des stars
bienvenue à cana à cannes il est aussi
des jeunes comédiens à l'honneur 20
d'entre eux ont été sélectionnés pour
faire partie de l'opération talents à
d'amicale une opération pour promouvoir
le talent de ces futures stars et parmi
les sélectionnés cette année à marc karm
el habib lourd originaire de
sartrouville
elle a été diplômée de l'école
supérieure d'art dramatique de la ville
de paris puis elle a intégré la comédie
française et on la retrouve ici à cannes
à la fiche de courts métrages merci
monsieur imada de sylvain chomet un
autre yvelinois dont on vous parlera
plus tard
je
l'histoire est simple ce sont quatre
comédiens jeunes comédiens dont qui
n'ont pas une expérience très développé
dans le cinéma de quatre jeunes
comédiens qui passe une audition pour un
réalisateur très très connu monsieur et
madame c'est un court métrage sur le
métier sûr
sur les jeunes comédiens sur le tournage
comment se déroule un tournage et c'est
une comédie très cynique aussi on rit on
grince des dents et on est ému en même
temps sur un première déjà le court
métrage en lui-même il me plaît beaucoup
donc je suis assez fier de montrer ce
travail là après ça serait mentir que de
dire que je m'en moque des retombées
tout ça non j'espère j'espère faire un
peu plus d'image comme je le disais et
puis c'est vrai que plus on travaille
plus on est vu plus on donne peut-être
envie à des réalisateurs des metteurs en
scène de travailler avec nous donc
donc voilà je vous le disais armelle
habibou est originaire de sartrouville
et bien c'est à sartrouville est
également que l'on a rencontré charlotte
marcos une jeune femme de 32 ans prof
d'anglais et qui vient de réaliser son
premier court métrage une trentaine de
personnes l'ont épaulé dans son projet
un projet qu'elle a payé en partie grâce
à un site de financement participatif
le résultat est plutôt bluffant voici
johnny and cash
c'est l'histoire de johnny car loser qui
vit que sur pour sa belle mustang et un
jour il fait des réparations sur sa
voiture mais n'a pas l'argent pour payer
donc pour rembourser sa dette il bosse
pour un boss mafieux
sauf que sa première mission vire au
drame et se poursuivre par trois
malfrats n'ont 1 en apprentissage si
pour moi comment je pouvais savoir tu es
un mec qui allait voler l'argent tu
comprends pas que ce poste va faire la
peau aux cookies tout dit
gégé a pris effectivement principalement
regardant des films regardés making of
en voyant comment il faisait et
et voilà j'ai essayé de faire un petit
peu mon style à moi même si ça sera
quand même très inspiré des films de
tarantino ça se verra ils ont tous
retrouvé
cher
et on se quitte avec notre star du jour
c'est un acteur né en 1978 il a donc 38
ans il a grandi à trappes dans les
yvelines
et s'il a raté son bac c'est parce qu'il
a suivi jamel debbouze à cannes l'année
de l'examen on l'a vu à la télévision
dans le sav des émissions puis au cinéma
dans intouchables
il s'agit vous l'aurez forcément deviner
d'omar sy l'acteur qui prête sa voix à
un personnage de film d'animation angry
birds un film actuellement dans les
salles dont il est venu assurer la
promotion ici à cannes sa lutte et le
fil 78
dans tout groupe civilisé il y à un
paria
dès son plus jeune âge le paria a du mal
à s'intégrer parfois se sentir invisible
et souvent ils peinent à se faire des
amis
mais malgré toutes ces difficultés le
paria persiste à vouloir tisser des
liens
cannes 78 c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
n'oubliez pas comme le dit fabrice
luchini le cinéma c'est une parenthèse
enchantée
oh
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de nous avoir suivis tout de suite vous
retrouvez sephora la manie pour la
magazine q est ce que votre magazine
culturel sur saint quentin en yvelines
je vous retrouve demain pour le journal
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée